hi there Steve here again Steve Kaufman
today I'm going to talk about listening
and speaking in language learning now in
a lot of these discussions by and large
I just get on here with a few ideas and
speak and you just listen I haven't got
it planned out what I'm gonna say to
begin with what I'm gonna say that
occasionally I do but mostly I don't so
perhaps my you know presentation wanders
a bit but it's as if we were sitting
down at you know some at an evening over
some coffee and talking you're just
listening to me and I just rant on and I
of course look forward to hearing your
comments and if anyone does send me a
video response I will usually you know
authorize it here at YouTube so that
people can see what other people are
saying um so the issue is listening and
speaking let me say up front that I
think that speaking as a part of
language learning is highly overrated
okay and I'm going to explain why I meet
a lot of people who tell me that they
are frustrated because they can't speak
the language as well as they would like
to so there's frustration at not being
able to speak well I meet people who
tell me that they can understand well
but they can't speak well but normally
in my experience that is not the case
there are people who read well and who
can't speak but I don't really recommend
erst and the spoken language well like
are totally comfortable listening and
understanding but who have trouble
speaking I have met a lot of people who
can speak and who seem to be able to
speak the language and don't understand
when you speak to them at a normal sort
of speed I believe that listening should
be that listening comprehension is the
fundamental skill in language
that is what you should drive for first
of all if you develop good listening
comprehension the other skills will come
the speaking will come even your grammar
your accuracy and all of these things
will come if you have had so much
exposure to the language that you
understand it when it is spoken by a
native speaker listening has a number of
other advantages it's very easy to
organize now the last I would say 10
days or so I've been focusing on Italian
because I want to do a video in Italian
and I had in my previous video I said
that I would leave a little trailer of a
little video shot of driving them to
Whistler listening to he promised he's
Posey where he talks about the lago di
como and we're driving by how sound and
you see the bit of the water in the
mountains and so forth I messed up
technologically so we didn't add that to
my last video I'm hoping in the work
today the point is that for the last 10
days I have been listening to a lot of
Italian I have been listening to e
promesa Sposi which I've been studying
here at link because I got the text I
can go through and save words I also
found this fascinating podcasts on radio
do way Alioto della Sera
and i've been listening to podcasts
about charlotte mine about you know alas
the history of cuisine mostly in Italy
Frederick the Great of Prussia and
learning about all kinds of stuff and
I'm so much enjoying my listening to
Italian that I have postponed doing my
video in Italian because the original
plan was I would do my video in Italian
I'd be off Italian and then I spend a
week on Swedish getting my Swedish up
and then I would do a video in Swedish
in a way I could just do the video but
they I just feel I may as well you know
be as you know brushed up as possible in
my languages but I don't want to leave
Italian because I'm having so much fun
you know and so the listening is so easy
to organise an hour and a half up to
Whistler an hour and a half back I'm
listening to Italian I'm in my car for
20 minutes to the office and back I'm
listening to Italian I just finished you
know doing the dishes and cleaning up
kitchen this one here I've got a little
dock that I can put it into so I'm not
always listening on my earphones I have
two different mp3 players I have
different stuff in each one of them I
have a variety of earphones these are
very good especially when my wife plays
the piano
I've got bees which are bluetooth so
they don't snare the wires on anything
I've got other ones for when I go
jogging or exercise I listen a lot I can
do it all the time and when I'm
listening it's not just that I'm
listening for the language I'm either
enjoying a novel or I'm learning about
history or and this is true in all
languages because the resources that are
available now the podcast of German for
checked for Russian for Italian for
Portuguese in any of the languages that
I've been dealing with the only one
where I haven't found anything that I
wanted really was in Korean but there's
lots of stuff out there to listen to I
could not have hired a tutor to sit
beside me in the car driving up to
Whistler to speak to me in Italian I
can't have someone standing by to speak
to me in Italian while I'm doing the
dishes so it's not that I don't speak I
do speak I've been speaking probably 3-4
hours a week three hours a week with our
tutors at Linc and it's great to do that
and I'm not saying one shouldn't speak
and I speak a lot better this week than
I did last week and the speaking and the
listening reinforce each other because
when I speak I made aware of my problems
where my hesitations and doubts are
where I don't know if I'm speaking
Spanish or Italian I get my Corrections
back from my tutor and it's amazing how
that makes you more observant of things
when you're listening and reading
especially reading and I should say
reading in a way is a form of listening
because when we read in a foreign
language we tend to sub vocalize to
start with the second of all reading in
other words the written language is just
another form of recording the spoken
language they didn't have first of all
to have no way of recording the spoken
language so everything was from memory
then we had right
to record the spoken language and
nowadays we have you know various ways
of recording the audio so that we can
listen to the audio so in a way I have
I'm not a neuroscientist but I think to
some extent that the brain is processing
the language the same way and getting
used to the language by this exposure to
the language but I'm having so much fun
with my Italian that I don't want to
leave it because I want to continue
listening to the rest of the story about
Shama Monte Carlo my mule in Italian and
this history of cooking in Italian and
I'm afraid that if I finish my Italian
video then I'll go on to Swedish and I
won't be able to enjoy those things I
think there's too much emphasis on
speaking at the beginning too much
emphasis on speaking correctly there's
too much pressure on people to produce
the language correctly at a stage in
their learning where they are unlikely
to be able to produce it directly
correct because they haven't had enough
exposure then they become overly
sensitive to the need to produce the
language correctly they second-guess
themselves they're hesitant to speak I
would say that the emphasis should be on
comprehension now I don't know how this
could be done in a classroom setting but
I do know as I've said many times that
in Canada where kids are taught French
for 10 years in the school's
english-speaking school system I don't
think there's 5% of those kids who
graduate being able to speak French so
it's a colossal failure even though
those same kids pass their tests every
year you know as as in all subjects a
few of them fail the bulk of them pass
theoretically the answered grammar
questions and at the end they still
can't speak they don't speak
grammatically correctly they have no
vocabulary they don't understand what
people are saying in the spoken language
they probably are able to read to some
extent so it's a colossal failure if
instead the focus was entirely on
helping those kids understand the
language so then the emphasis would be
on finding things that interest them
perhaps working on vocabulary allowing
them to watch movies looting doing a lot
of things that appear to be passive
possibly letting them read in the
classroom rather than taking turns
reading from a book where they all
or mangle the language if those kids
graduated with the ability to understand
the language that was the only objective
that any speaking activity is only there
in order to basically prime the pump and
to make them more aware of certain
things in the language but not to test
them on their ability to speak by all
means speak because I think speaking is
good it's it's it's helping to to
stimulate again the brain to to notice
the language better but the objective of
a speaking is not to be tested on the
speaking the speaking is just an
exercise in improving your comprehension
ability and if at the end of this period
people graduate being able to understand
the language well if they then want to
learn to speak they'll be able to learn
to speak very quickly if someone
graduates from say French and a Canadian
school and goes off to Quebec or France
and they fully understand what people
are saying they will learn to speak very
quickly they'll have much more
confidence going into that if on the
other hand they have some vague notions
of the 16 verbs that take at and
something about gender and limited
vocabulary and don't really understand
they will go to France and they will be
lost and it'll take them a long long
time to improve so I repeat I believe
that listening is more powerful in
language learning than speaking it's
more easy to arrange we have powerful
tools that make it better than ever we
have resources available on the Internet
it should be the prime focus of language
learning first of all learn to
understand the spoken language and learn
to understand it well and that means
acquiring a lot of words now just to
give you an illustration of how one can
be y'all should add to that the
advantage of listening is and of course
you have to get past that initial stage
where you're listening to silly things
for beginners not by the way kiddies
stories which I find are more difficult
because they use more strange vocabulary
than simple stories designed for the
learner you can't get away from it for
the first month or two but as soon as
possible move into the real stuff try to
have text available so that you can
look up the words and increase your
vocabulary much as we do it link and
then get on to things that are of
interest and and then it just becomes so
fascinating you're hardly aware that you
know you're learning a language you're
learning things about you know shallow
man you move like if I listen to
promises Posey which is a novel written
in the 19th century about Italy in the
16th century or 17th century
you're not only you're taken into a
different language world a different
cultural world if you want a different
historical world you're learning about
things it's a marvelous experience it's
a much more rewarding experience than
struggling to use the language when you
have no words so yes we need to speak
and eventually to speak well you need to
speak a lot but step one is to be able
to understand the spoken language on a
variety of subjects that should be goal
number one and I will leave you then
with this narrative from Ypres mrs.
palsey hopefully it works while I'm
driving up to Whistler
so I'm driving in the 21st century but
I'm in a world about the 17th century
written by someone in the 19th century
thank you for listening bye for now
quelle heure a motor lago di como que
voce amezo Giorno Treadway Katainen
uninterrupted amanti to TOA Senegal fee
a seconded ellos Porcello B entrar le
queenly VN o a giant rat Oh arrest Rinty
OC aprender co so II figured if you may
[ __ ] Ramon Toria destra L nambia cos
tierra de la otra parte del Ponte ke V
Kahn jr. de Guerra de tal K Rendon Corp
you sensible alok EO questa trasfer man
Savona SNL Punto en Quelaag o Chezza
de la de perón cometa peripheral airpo
no mira la godo very ribbit
elantra lo c di nuovo lation lacroix
dice tender see aerelon tal si MOV Col
Fatima Vasily Lacoste ii-era formatted
and apposite OD trach receipt or NT Chen
Leopold ratted way Monty contigo e Bruno
de toda Sammartino la TRO kombucha
lombarda yer a Ciccone dellamorta Sueko
cuts or in Fela Henry roll off a Nozomi
tra una Sega Turk a known a key a primo
very low porque si a different a Comey
perez de MP only surah Merrin Imran okay
Parton assitant Rihanna nirodha genital
contra Sega in Quetta lunga basta yoga
Dalia al Tremonti diamond apos
era for mchao como Peru empezó la Costas
ra con un Pelle do lento a contigo para
siempre en o GN Valon